madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal les armées européennes unissent
leurs pas pour le traditionnel défilé du
14 juillet une grande parade militaire
devant quelques 12000 maires de france
l'interview de jacques chirac en direct
de l'elysée des propos plutôt sévère à
l'égard de la politique économique du
gouvernement qui suscite de nombreuses
réactions la libération d'un otage
malaisie aux philippines enlevé en avril
dernier il s'agit du deuxième
ressortissant de ce pays des tenues par
les rebelles qui retrouve donc la
liberté l'esprit de la fête était bien
là mais sous les parapluies l'incroyable
pique nique la méridienne verte avec
venus en moins grand nombre que prévu
les adeptes de ce repas géant c'est donc
sous un ciel changeant que s'est déroulé
ce matin sous le signe de l'europe le
traditionnel défilé du 14 juillet un
défilé qui arborait les doubles couleur
celle de la naissance europe de la
défense et celle des élus municipaux
deux idées forces la première représenté
par quelques 12000 mer ce qui incarne la
france de la république
la seconde incarné par les armées
européennes ou même pas de descendant
les champs elysées dorothée cochard
une volée de lutins tout à coup sûr les
champs elysées on attendait des
militaires ce furent d'abord des enfants
jamais défilé national ne s'était montré
aussi pacifique
et c'est bien là l'esprit qu'on a voulu
donner à ce 14 juillet pour la première
fois huit pays ont été invités à parader
aux côtés des soldats français
si l'espagne ses côtés l'allemagne la
belgique les pays bas le luxembourg le
portugal la grande bretagne dont pour la
petite histoire il a fallu très sympa et
l'italie que l'on a dû freiner l'entente
européenne est aussi une affaire de
cadence
au total seulement 58 hommes à pied les
effectifs sont maigres mais tout est
dans le symbole l'autriche en sait
quelque chose les chasseurs alpins
tirelire n'ont pas été conviés l'union
européenne est en froid avec le
gouvernement autrichien d'extrême droite
pour le reste des filets suit la
tradition défilé des écoles
prestigieuses polytechnique saint cyr
et l'incontournable légion étrangère au
total sept mille trois cents hommes sans
d'aéronefs 270 chevaux 400 véhicules
ce défilé le plus important organisé en
occident depuis la disparition de l'urss
et de ses mémorables parade sur la place
rouge de moscou à deux ans de la fin
programmée du service national dans une
période où les derniers sursitaire font
pression pour l'exemption général
l'armée a voulu montrer qu'elle pouvait
encore tenir son rang il malgré les
caprices du temps bien ce très
conviviale le land de la méridienne
l'incroyable pique nique qu'il s'est
déroulé sous une incroyable météo
gâchant n'ont pas l'esprit de la fête
mais diminuant considérablement le
nombre des adeptes de ce pique nique
géant qui a traversé la france entière
reportage elsa marc bouche ils marient
mais l'incroyable météo aurait pu faire
de ce pique nique un incroyable flop
mais le français ne se laisse pas si
facilement couper l'appétit
incroyable mais vrai il y eut bien à gap
dans les prés malgré le froid malgré la
pluie oui là les mouvements à quelqu'un
pour finir les paie pas le temps d'en
savoir toujours espoir aux noix
du nord au sud de la france sur près de
1000 km on fit donc fi du ciel couvert
les esprits chagrins notre rang bien que
l'incroyable facture de ce pique nique
géant s'élève quand même à 38 en france
et ce n'est pas l'appétit des convives
qui a salé l'addition
chacun devant amener son voir et son
manger qu'à cela ne tienne
l'essentiel c'est que la convivialité
était bien au rendez vous pour digérer
tout ça il fallait au moins un
incroyable défi sportif
1re les géants parti simultanément du
nord et du sud de la france
un relais qui volent marché court 500
sportifs de tout poil se sont passé le
témoin depuis 24 heures le long de la
méridienne à orly les avions en suspens
dire même leur vol le temps d'un petit
tour de piste
aux dernières nouvelles certains courte
encore allez courage
l'arrivée est proche
en effet cette jonction des équipes nord
et sud aura lieu en direct à la fin de
ce journal
mais nous sommes maintenant au rendez
vous politique de ce 14 juillet avec
pendant près de cinquante cinq minutes
et sur des sujets d'actualité
l'interview de jacques chirac en direct
du palais de l'elysée le chef de l'état
qui a revendiqué son rôle d'éclaireur et
d'acteurs dans la vie politique
française
morceaux choisis sur le référendum la
corse et la mairie de paris avec jean
baptiste près des marquis son rôle et sa
place cette année jacques chirac c'est
surtout voulu offensif premier sujet le
prochain référendum sur le quinquennat
là il s'agissait de convaincre des
français tentés par l'abstention c'est
moi je fais confiance aux français ne
faut jamais avoir peur d'interroger les
français
alors vous imaginez bien que je ne vais
pas aller
comment dirais-je battre les estrades
mais j'ai dit aux français ce que ma
réflexion m'avait conduit leur proposer
je souhaite qu'il réponde favorablement
le 14 juillet c'est surtout l'occasion
de commenter des sujets politiques
d'actualité celui du jour la corse et
l'éventuelle évolution de son fait mais
et le corse arrêter une position ils
sont en train de la formaliser ils vont
la présenter au gouvernement lequel
prendra sa décision si naturellement
j'attendrai pour m'exprimer de savoir
quelles sont les propositions et quelle
est la décision du gouvernement
je dirais simplement que c'est un moment
important pour la course important est
que chacun doit être conscient de sa
responsabilité dans le respect de
l'unité de la république
enfin on attendait le président de la
république sur un sujet sensible la
mairie de paris l'ancien maire de la
capitale de 1977 à 1995 l'a affirmé il
n'a rien à voir avec la faire des faux
électeurs concernant sa place dans la
sphère des électeurs fantômes est ce que
vous avez le sentiment
cela jette le discrédit sur la gestion
de la ville de paris est-ce que ça me
choque gens me choquerait profonde et ça
me choque profondément
l'idée me choque profondément reste
naturellement à en apporter la preuve
la justice est saisie et bien qu'elle
fasse son travail gestion d'une ville
comme paris est une affaire considérable
considérable pour un air vous imaginez
bien que je n'étais pas en permanence
derrière chacun des 5 120 ou 130 élus
parisiens et avoir effectué le mans
derrière chacun des quelque quarante
mille fonctionnaires parisiens pour
assurer qu'aucune irrégularité ou ou
qu'aucune faute n'a été commise
s'il ya des fraudeurs justice le dira et
je n'ai rien à ajouter à cela
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état se voulait
éclairer acteurs de la vie publique en
55 minutes il s'est expliqué sans
oublier de critiquer le gouvernement
concernant les questions économiques et
sociales jacques chirac a tenu un
discours particulièrement incisif à
l'égard du gouvernement constatant selon
lui que malgré la croissance retrouvée
le pouvoir d'achat des français ne
demandent pas nous sommes dans une
période de croissance forte et le
pouvoir d'achat n'augmente pas
à ma connaissance c'est sans précédent
pourquoi l'exemple des 35 heures
cela crée des comportements dans les
entreprises qui consiste à bloquer des
salaires est ce que c'est un grand
progrès peut s'interroger
nous devons profiter de nos moyens
d'une part pour engager un processus de
réduction d'une charge fiscale et de
prélèvements général qui sont en franc
supérieurs à ceux de tous nos voisins ce
qui crée pour nous un handicap
c'est une première priorité la deuxième
c'est la réduction de nos déficits quand
vous pensez que chaque jour nous aime
nous créons chaque jour ouvrable en
france nous créons un milliard de plus
de dettes dire ça peut pas durer
indéfiniment
il faut profiter de la croissance pour
résorber ce qui sans simple pèsera
lourdement sur nos enfants qui devront
peu le rembourser par leurs impôts le
résultat est positif
ils échangent aucun doute positif pour
les chômeurs qui verront plus leurs
prestations s'améliorer et positifs pour
les entreprises et pour les salariés
je crois donc que cela va dans la bonne
direction si tout le monde respecte ses
engagements et notamment si les
entreprises respectent leurs engagements
et puis deuxièmement je trouve que c'est
tout à fait caractéristique d'une
évolution vers une démocratie sociale si
l'on devait arriver à l'étatisation
d'assurance-chômage ce serait un
extraordinaire recul pour ce qui
concerne une démocratie sociale dont je
souhaite au contraire qu'elles se
développent et je me retourne tout de
suite vers vous et rare leclerc comment
analyser les propos de jacques chirac
qui a ouvertement critiqué la politique
du gouvernement
je crois qu'on peut dire qu'on a vu
trois jacques chirac qui se complète
d'ailleurs d'abord le cohabitant
consensuel le chef de l'état entend
poursuivre une cohabitation sans tension
car dit il c'est ce qu'ont voulu les
français aussi approuve-t-il prudemment
l'a entendu le dialogue engagé sur
l'accord saint jacques chirac est apparu
plutôt serein et détendu
sauf peut-être sur les affaires
parisiennes mais le président aussi
peaufiner l'image d'un modernisateur de
la démocratie il faut dit-il la
revitaliser au plan politique c'est le
quinquennat est le référendum au plus
en local avec plus de décentralisation
au plan social avec davantage de
négociations contractuelles ou encore au
plan européen avec la constitution qu'il
appelle de ses voeux
et puis jacques chirac s'est placée en
éclaireur de la nation oui mais un
éclaireur qui met le projecteur sur les
zones d'ombré ou supposés tels de
l'action du gouvernement par exemple la
sécurité qui se banaliserait le pouvoir
d'achat qui ne progresserait pas malgré
la croissance
les excès de réglementation ou
l'insuffisance des baisses d'impôts ou
des déficits alors la charge certes
mesuré dans le ton présente un risque
celui d'apparaître comme le leader de
l'opposition auquel les ministres
notamment le premier d'entre eux ne
manqueront pas de répondre vertement
dans les jours qui viennent
martine aubry l'a d'ailleurs déjà fait
aujourd'hui sur la fracture sociale
alors je résume un président qui se veut
consensuel moderne et portant un projet
d'avenir différent de son challenger
n'y at il pas là trois thèmes majeurs
pour une campagne pour une deuxième
candidature à l'elysée même si
l'intéressé a répété aujourd'hui même
que le moment n'était pas venu d'en
parler merci gérard avec wenger
tradition oblige la garden party dans
les jardins de l'elysée et tradition
obligent les nombreuses réactions
politiques aux propos du chef de l'état
ici on applaudit et laon tempête vers
une excentive
garden party à l'elysée comme au théâtre
pendant deux heures les invités jouent
leur rôle
ils se côtoient ils s'entretiennent il
s'est vite les inconnus comme les stars
parler à voix haute de la météo et à
voix basse de la politique
côté police bernadette chirac réserve un
accueil particulier aux candidats à la
mairie de paris
côté jardin
sylviane jospin assure la promotion de
son mari mais le premier ministre fixe
lui même les limites
et puis il ya tous ceux qui se montrent
tous ceux qui prennent d'assaut les
buffets et tous ceux qui comptent sur
les autres pour leur raconter
l'interview du président la république
retransmis sur grand écran
il a réussi à faire passer jospin pour
le chef de file de la france ringarde et
conservatrice s'agissant de de ses
relations avec le premier ministre je
recule a été assez clair
lui c'est lui et le premier ministre
c'est le premier ministre qui a un
certain nombre de choses qui ne vont pas
le président de la république s'est
étonné qu'en dépit d'une croissance
forte le pouvoir d'achat des français ne
suivent pas à gauche on n'apprécie pas
peut-être que il incite
les gens se syndiquer davantage et à
revendiquer et c'est un bonne idée
jacques chirac a voulu se poser en
éclaireur et il est vrai qu'à 18 mois de
l'élection présidentielle il a surtout
contribué à éclairer les français sur
ces thèmes de campagne de 2002 et
jacques chirac a voulu avoir le dernier
mot un mot pour les germains racines de
cette démocratie de demain les racines
ont apprécié et c'était le regard des
deux parties celle de l'an 2000 ans
il n'est juste pas qui est arrivé dans
son fief de cintegabelle en fin de
journée pour participer au traditionnel
le quai sous les républicains le premier
ministre qui n'a pas souhaité commenter
les propos de jacques chirac
et pendant ce temps là dans les jardins
du sénat se déroulait la fête de la
fédération de l'an 2000 invités vedettes
les maires de france sein de leur
écharpe tricolore
une célébration en forme d'un immense
banquet spirit de la fête du 14 juillet
1790 avec en clôture un splendide lâcher
de ballons thierry clopeau françois
granier à neuf mois des prochaines
municipales
il y avait dans les jardins du
luxembourg un parfum de réconciliation
au delà des partis 11000 maire de droite
de gauche en passant par les centres et
pour ce dernier grand banquet
républicain du siècle pas un seul point
de discorde c'est la fête de la concorde
ouvriers je viens de tomber sur fa bus
on s'est embrassés il ya longtemps quand
c'est pas vu aujourd'hui c'est la
république et ce sont les valeurs
fondamentales de la république thomas
nous ferons la confrontation mais demain
ça le beurre et au petit jeu des belles
heures républicaine chacun y est allé de
cette définition et la fraternité c'est
une façon de vivre ensemble c'est le
respect de règles républicaines ce sont
des cérémonies ont l'esprit de citoyens
nous ne prenons pas la considération que
vous avez pour les maires de france avec
vous on sait qu'on est bien pendue merci
murs des palais du fatah la justice et
les différentes mises en examen pas
toujours comprise par les élus locaux
ils sont quelques-uns à elle souhaitait
des plus petites communes
le maire et responsable oui et porter
responsable pour plein de choses
n'étaient pas normales à la première de
france
les élus sont souvent pour différentes
raisons en première ligne il ya sans
aucun doute un problème il faut il faut
que l'opinion s'en rend compte
devant ce malaise pas tant le sénat a
voulu rassurer les inquiets tendance
bien sûr déterminer ce qu'est la faute
intentionnelle de la folle faire un
intentionnel pour éviter que les mères
soit presque quotidiennement yannick
jamais alors qu'ils n'ont aucun rapport
avec la synchronie cohabitation oblige
jacques chirac lui aussi présent affirmé
être résolument partisan d'un statut de
l'élu
les 11000 mer sont repartis confiant et
surtout rompu ils ont fait le plein de
force avant de l'échéance de l'an
prochain et du sénat précisément ce pavé
dans la mare de jean pierre chevènement
le ministre de l'intérieur commentant
les revendications des élus corses n'a
pu s'empêcher de les mettre ouvertement
en garde et ce à quelques jours de la
dernière réunion à matignon
je vous propose d'écouter vous ai dit
qu'il est très facile de demander le
produit de l'impôt 1 et puis ensuite le
pouvoir de faire la loi
l'argent l'argent du beurre et puis
demain ce sera à l'anis tissé de dire
l'impunité donc je profite dire qu'il y
a quand même un dialogue sérieux un kiki
est nécessaire
on ne peut pas empêcher tout ce que le
gouvernement propose est encore en
demander davantage
vous comprenez bien que je ne suis pas
pour une souveraineté corps je pense que
la corse fait partie de la république
pour moi les corses sont des français et
je ne considère pas les corses comme des
kanaks qui d'une certaine manière chante
aussi des français mais dans un
territoire d'outre-mer et qui bénéficie
d'un statut entièrement dérogatoire en
ce 14 juillet dans toutes les pensées à
commencer par celle de jacques chirac
les otages retenus aux philippines dont
six français
aujourd'hui c'est un malaisien enlevés
en avril dernier qui a été libéré
commentaires et sabine est un peu perdu
qui ont surpris par sa liberté retrouvée
oui jawa salah watts le second malaisien
libéré ce matin par les rebelles du
groupe abou sayyaf
il est fermement encadrée par robert
avant de taradeau le chef des
négociateurs qui ne souhaite pas voir
son protégé s'exprimer non ont des
raisons de sécurité nous ne souhaitons
pas le laisser répondre à vos questions
tout ce que nous pouvons dire c'est que
le gouvernement de malaisie a promis des
investissements sociaux dans la région
hier les ministres des affaires
étrangères de finlande d'allemagne et de
france était à manille pour convaincre
les autorités philippines de ne pas
utiliser la manière forte
l'occasion de divulguer une lettre d'un
des captifs finlandais le moral des
otages écrit-il se détériore s'il vous
plaît faites le maximum pour nous sortir
de là de manière pacifique
on hésite cet après midi à pékin le chef
de la diplomatie français hubert védrine
se disait confiant dans le travail des
autorités philippines
je les ai trouvés je dois dire la manie
vraiment engagés dans cette affaire
vraiment me disais vraiment conscients
de leurs responsabilités et animés de la
volonté de réussir
jacques chirac quant à lui a rappelé son
investissement personnel dans cette
affaire qu'il suit jour après jour dans
un contexte de très grande confusion car
on ne sait pas exactement en réalité ce
que veulent ces gens nous faisons tous
et par tous les moyens d'une part pour
importer
un peu de ce d'autant qu'ils ont besoin
ces otages
sur le plan matériel et sur le plan
moral et d'autres pas apprécié de
trouver la solution qui nous permette
qui nous permettra de les récupérer
cette nouvelle libération représente un
espoir mais surtout c'est aussi le signe
que les négociations ont effectivement
repris après trois semaines
d'interruption
aux etats unis la 4e journée du sommet
de camp david
ehud barak et yasser arafat savent
qu'ils médiatement après le sommet la
bataille de l'opinion publique
commencera en cas d'échec qu'il faudra
en expliquer les raisons en cas de
succès par contre il faudra justifier
les compromis peut être douloureux qui
leur a fallu faire de part et d'autre
mais déjà une véritable propagande a
débuté sur place aux états unis
reportage de notre envoyée spéciale
charles enderlin d'ici les ministres
israéliens arrivés en renfort sont
dirigés vers les points sensibles par
exemple dans le centre de presse de ce
remonte proche de candé vide
le rabbin melchior propage la bonne
parole il est ministre du cabinet barak
chargé des communautés juives
je suis persuadé dit il que le public
israélien approuvera massivement
l'accord qui sera conclu
à quand des vides de fêtes et autres
baraques a déjà confié ionic koren un
publicitaire de tel-aviv le soin de
préparer le référendum qui devrait
suivre la conclusion d'un accord
ami personnel du premier ministre il se
trouve déjà à washington
yasser arafat lui compte presque
exclusivement sur anna choc elle est la
porte parole bien connu de la cause
palestinienne dans la capitale fédérale
elle multiplie les in terris franchement
nous sommes des défavorisés à tous
points de vue
c'est notre terre qui est occupé et
objectivement nous sommes les faibles
n'avons ni soutien ni personnel star
mais il ya aussi la scène intérieure
palestinienne
arafat a demandé à trois membres de
l'exécutif de l'olp et devenir attendent
évident pour des consultations
ces dirigeants du pc palestinien et du
front démocratique sont aux etats unis
opposés à toute concession palestinienne
ils ne sont pas pour l'instant autorisée
à rencontrer leur président permet de
winton ne veut pas changer les règles
sommet auquel seuls peuvent participer
les négociateurs et n'ont rien ne filtre
si ce n'est une confirmation
bill clinton pense toujours qu'un accord
israélo-palestinien est possible d'ici
mardi prochain en france pour ce long
week-end du 14 juillet la suite des
départs sur la route des vacances une
journée plutôt calme côté circulation en
revanche terrible accident hier soir
près de metz faisant cinq morts et smina
farber la pluie une vitesse excessive et
le break mercedes rate son virage la
voiture traverse le terre-plein central
s'envole sur 30 mètres avant de percuter
un camping car immatriculé en belgique
la passagère meurt sur le coup son mari
décédera à l'hôpital quelques heures
plus tard
le break est totalement disloqué à son
bord trois morts et trois miraculés dont
un enfant de 11 ans la route des
vacances était fluide
les autorités parlent de prises de
risques de l'enseignement qu'on peut
retirer à cette heure c'est que avec une
circulation fluide les automobilistes
ont tendance à méconnaître les
limitations de vitesse est à croire qu
ils peuvent
les à l'aller est en folie les services
de la préfecture venait de recenser ce
tronçon d'autoroute comme dangereux il y
à peine une semaine il avait changé la
limitation de vitesse à 90 km/heure le
plus grand voilier du monde à quatre
mâts battant pavillon russe n'a pu
participer à la fête navale
internationale brest 2000 le sedov c'est
son nom est bloqué à kehl l'état russe
ayant plusieurs millions de dollars de
dettes le navire a été confisqué
stéphane wagner il y a quelques jours
cette merveille de la marine russe
naviguer sur les océans depuis hier le
cdh off est immobilisé à brest
interdiction de prendre le large la
justice française a ordonné la saisie du
bateau
tout simplement parce que nos gars une
société suisse d'import-export réclame
près de 400 millions de francs à l'état
russe
il existe des actifs et en l'occurrence
un bateau je le saisis
maintenant si la fédération de russie
veut permettre le bon déroulement de
bresse 2000 il lui appartient de payer
ce qu'elle doit
cette immobilisation du cdh of fait
partie des nombreuses saisies qu'à
demander nos gars pour récupérer ses
créances
en tout la fédération de russie doit 7
milliards de francs à la société suisse
un coup dur pour brest 2000 un coup dur
aussi pour les finances du bateau le
plus grand voilier du monde vit surtout
des sous-locations entreprises qui
payent 150 mille francs par jour quant
aux 200 membres d'équipage ils subissent
soutenu par les organisateurs avec la
devise des maras et faire avec trois qui
font avec aussi on essaie de les aider
au mieux
le dossier est maintenant entre les
mains du ministre de la justice
elisabeth guigou
seule une décision du procureur pourrait
permettre au cdh offre de rejoindre
douarnenez lundi prochain mais tout cela
n'a pas empêché le bon déroulement de la
fête nautique à brest avec ce défi
relevé par de jeunes européens de
reconstruire à la façon du xviiie siècle
de très longues chaloupe qui ont pris le
départ d'une régate aujourd'hui thierry
kurt et thierry breton du rayon de
soleil pour la couleur et la foule pour
l'ambiance
faut pas seulement intéressés par les
grands voiliers mais surtout par le
patrimoine maritime dans toute sa
richesse loti le long des trois mâts 28
yole de bantry longue chaloupés filet du
xviiie siècle
elles ont été construites à l'initiative
du magazine le chasse-marée véritable
phare de la défense de ce patrimoine
à chaque fête de brest il lance un
concours la mission du chasse-marée c2c
d'intéresser la jeune génération
patrimoine maritime c'est de lui
transmettre tous les gestes et tous les
savoirs des anciens qui savent faire
naviguer des bateaux comme la
recouvrance ou comme les n'importe quel
bateau traditionnel de pêche des côtes
françaises aient cessées attirer la
jeunesse vers le patrimoine maritime
c'est transmettre ce savoir des anciens
dans la rade tous les jours on reggae
c'est la récompense pour ceux qui ont
construit ces yole de bantry hélas pas
de quartier certains échantillons
étaient l'occasion d'opérations de
réinsertion et l'on découvre que ce
patrimoine maritime ou fluviale captive
aussi à trappes mots en région
parisienne à troyes en champagne et même
en suisse
le voyage fait rêver mais il faut
parfois ramer pour mettre les voiles
aujourd'hui on râle contre c'est vrai
les yoles si pas toujours la galère mais
la voile n'est qu'accessoire ici là où
on parle de patrimoine
on respecte forcément les traditions
ceux qui gagnent la régate puis disent
toujours à l'eau le tour de france
cycliste aujourd'hui victoire de
vincente garcia acosta l'espagne elle a
remporté en solitaire cette 13e étape de
la grande boucle 185 km courue entre
avignon et draguignan
à la veille de la première bataille dans
les alpes s'élancera vers briançon 145
coureurs restent en lice et puis sur la
route du tour un accident à ginasservis
dans le var un enfant de 12 ans a été
percuté par un véhicule de la caravane
victime d'un traumatisme crânien est
blessé au fémur il ensuite été évacuée
par hélicoptère à marseille
revenons aux festivités du 14 juillet
avec ce relais sportif parti hier soir à
20 heures les équipes du nord et du sud
qui ont accompli un long périple pour se
rejoindre dans ce journal
une performance sportive que nous relate
florent muller le sel a rendez vous avec
le poivre sur la petite place de
treignac dans les villages alentour on
célèbre les derniers kilomètres des
héros de l'incroyable relais partie d'un
contenu d'un kart et de l'autre de prace
les mouiller pour l'heure le poivre
venus du sud se fait attendre alors les
prochains relayeur nous livre les
secrets de leur forme
comme on vieillit on fait de plus en
plus de biathlon nous chez dim
c'est à dire vélo et puis une petite
bouffe après quand même les voilà enfin
mais ici on prend le temps d'apprécier
les bonnes choses et le passage du bâton
n'a rien d'olympique le compte n'y est
pas un grain n'a été moulues l'équipe
peut à nouveau ses lancers et c'est bien
connu le poivre ça soude tout au long de
cette dérive des condiments treignat
poursuivi son agapes gargantuesque et le
ciel est basé lourd et n'a aucune pitié
très vite il faut quitter lé inondable
nappe pour trouver une place dans un
refuge plus au sec une légère entrave à
la fête qui ne coupe pas l'appétit
car le bourbonnais a réponse à tout la
pluie du matin n'arrête pas le pèlerin
et c'est votre devise aujourd'hui vous
allez voir vous voyez le soleil car
pendant ce temps là les relayeurs ont
encore du grain à moudre ils n'ont plus
que quelques hectomètres à avaler avant
l'arrivée à thénia où on les attend en
fanfare
m
mais précisément le point de jonction de
ce relais se trouve à treignat où nous
retrouvons en direct louis carzou au
moment même où les équipes arrivent sel
et poivre en main écoutez béatrice on
attend d'une minute à l'autre l'arrivée
du sel et du poivre ici au point de
jonction à treignac dans l'allier très
bien où doit donc se dérouler le point
d'orgue de cette incroyable relais
sportif incroyable 14 juillet le dernier
du siècle je pense que c'est du côté du
sel et de jean-marie qu'on a un peu de
difficulté à arriver du côté du poivre
et avec florence qui se trouve juste
derrière moi eh bien on est déjà arrivé
on attend la jonction d'une minute à
l'autre et donc c'est ici à trédias dans
l'allier qui est un point de jonction
naturel puisque c'est également le point
de jonction entre la langue d'oil et la
langue d'oc
c'est un village qui a eu quelques
difficultés pour l'instant avec la météo
puisque il y avait des intempéries très
forte jusqu'à il ya quelques heures le
beau soleil est arrivé pour cette fête
du 14 juillet le sel et le poivre
devrait arriver d'un moment à l'autre
mais pour l'instant points de celle
point de poivre et je me trouve donc
avec jean jacques aillagon le président
de la mission des festivités de l'an
2000 et michel dufour le secrétaire
d'état à l'action culturelle
décentralisée
alors jean jacques aillagon j'ai un peu
envie de vous demander est ce que vous
êtes heureux de ces deux déroulement de
cette manifestation
j'en suis très très heureux tout cas
michel dufour qui vient de parcourir la
moitié de la france pour voir les effets
de l'incroyable vite nique
oui c'est un très grand succès pour les
élus locaux pour les bénévoles les
associations une incroyable idée qui a
eu aujourd'hui un très beau succès et
puis donc ici attrayant on attend
toujours l'arrivée du sel et du poivre
alors quand même on a une recette à
treignac qui permet à aux sportifs qui
ont un petit peu de difficulté de
reprendre des forces avant d'aller
danser ce soir puisque avec ce beau
temps les bals les concerts prévus à
très bien vont pouvoir avoir lieu comme
prévu donc la recette c'est tout
simplement la recette du pâté aux pommes
de terre vous prenez une couche de pâte
feuilletée une couche de pommes de terre
puis de nouveau une couche de pâte
feuilletée et croyez-moi béatrice si
vous arrosez généreusement de crème
fraîche et bien ça requinque ça donne
des forces pour aller faire la fête ce
soir mais sans sel sans preuve sans
doute
une page scientifique avec quatre ans de
retard le lancement de mad de la base de
baïkonour de cette élite qui pour la
première fois
environ des images en trois dimensions
avec pour objectif d'étudier
l'interaction entre les vents solaires
et la terre à nice monte c'était il ya
quatre ans le vol 501 de qualification
d'ariane 5
à son bord quatre satellites de la
mission cluster en quelques secondes un
nuage de poussière
le désastre est réelle mais il existe un
prototype un centième cluster baptisé
immédiatement phoenix il permettra au
projet de renaître de ses cendres
aujourd'hui quatre clusters sont de
nouveaux prêts deux d'entre eux seront
lancées demain de baïkonour emporté par
une fusée soyouz
les deux derniers les rejoindront le 9
août prochain dans l'espace ils
étudieront la magnétosphère terrestre ce
bouclier magnétique qui isole et protège
la terre une barrière contre les vents
solaires charge et d'électrons de
protons et des ions
mais parfois les éruptions solaires sont
plus intenses ces bouffées de chaleur
traverse la magnétosphère elle se
concentre au col
apparaissent alors les aurores boréales
et australes
comme ici filmé en accéléré
un spectacle somptueux dont les pays
nordiques qui devraient bénéficier la
semaine prochaine avec un peu de chance
conséquences plus dramatiques les orages
géomagnétiques ils peuvent être à
l'origine d'importantes coupures
électriques comme en 1989 au canada les
quatre satellites kloster sont en fait
des pionniers de la météo
interplanétaire ils permettront entre
autres de mieux comprendre l'impact des
vents solaires sur notre climat et nous
retournons tout de suite at régna ou
louis carzou je crois qu'en fait le
relais est arrivé tout à fait la
béatrice jean-marie et flan font donc
arrivé sous les vivats de la foule ici à
treignat florence avec le sell jean
marie avec le poivre qui vont remettre
donc un michel dufour et à jean jacques
aillagon
les deux épices pour leur rassemblement
enfin ici à très bien ou quand même il
faut signaler qu'il ya quelques 10000
personnes rassemblées sur la place de
très bien un village qui comme
d'habitude à peine 400 habitants voilà
ça y est c'est les poivres et bien
maintenant que la fête commence
une première au festival d'avignon une
comédie musicale le six auteurs
contemporains ont écrit s'y livrer dont
le thème que miles regard acide qu'il
porte sur notre société
une démonstration joyeuse que nous
commente michel celui-ci est devenu
beney
le festival d'avignon se dévergonde la
comédie musicale fait ici une entrée
tonitruante elle met en scène notre
société elle en dénoncent avec ironie
les tares comme ici la volonté de
traiter comme une déviance individuel le
drame du chômage
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises
établissent que 95% des personnes
étudiées reçoivent correctement
l'annoncent d'un licenciement à la
détresse de ce monsieur comme à la
couleur hauteur fond monsieur vous
pouvez demander pourquoi
les explications à tout point commun
c'est que toutes ces petites pièces
parlent de la france aujourd'hui en
utilisant souvent le vocabulaire de la
musique que de la comédie musicale en
fait l'idée de du du spectacle laisser
faire à travers six pièces si comédie
musicale qui parle de maintenant cet
hommage aux parapluies de cherbourg de
jacques demy se termine comme il se doit
par un coup de foudre
ainsi se termine ce journal sans appel
les deux principaux titres l'interview
de jacques chirac en direct de l'elysée
des propos plutôt sévère à l'égard de la
politique économique du gouvernement
propos qui suscitent de nombreuses
réactions la libération d'un otage
malaisie aux philippines n'a enlevé en
avril dernier il s'agit du deuxième
ressortissant de ce pays des tenues par
les rebelles qui retrouve donc la
liberté tout de suite la météo patrice
drevet 20h52 votre série policière pj
serrures 30 le dernier journal présenté
par helen hughes
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sur france 2
je
heures